I have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p call
anytime here's a voicemail that i
received uh yes this is al from tampa
and uh I wanted to ask David uh a couple
one just one thing you're on free speech
TV but every time you play something
that has a bad word in it you bleep them
well then what good is that if you're
supposed to be on free p free speech TV
yeah uh good mind answering that thank
you listen I get it it we we are on FCC
regulated stations both on television
and on radio so it's not that I want to
be censoring bad words it's that if we
don't our broadcast affiliates can get
fined as and as much as I would like to
unilaterally decide that you can get in
trouble anymore for for putting up bad
words on your radio or television
channel you still can and I don't want
to get our stations in trouble that's
just sort of the reality so I agree I I
wish we didn't have to deal with that
but we do in order to be on these
broadcast affiliates on today's bonus
show we will talk about listening clubs
in London it's pretty wacky but
interesting i'll tell you about it we
will also tell you we've covered
discrimination against those who suffer
from albinism i will tell you about an
albino beauty pageant that is going on
and also an overdue book returned after
42 years reminds me of a Seinfeld
episode but it is all too real you can
get the bonus show access by signing up
a david pakman.com slash membership and
hey if you want a free 2017 david pakman
show calendar with your membership just
go to david pakman.com slash calendar 17
and you can get the calendar for free
with your yearly membership